so dick Knight is being released on
itunes looks like cable on demand amazon
xbox do you expect this release to
impact your life at all in terms of
freedom lifestyle because of that what
type of expectations do you have for
that I mean it's gonna impact you know
it without a doubt just because it's
such a small movie to get this kind of
release you know in some way to
legitimize is all this effort you put
into it and so you know it would
probably take a lot for the movie to
become you know really impactful
financially I think in terms of take a
lot I mean then we would really have to
hit or some people would really have to
like tastemakers get behind it but I
think the bigger impactor in what you
you know kind of you know me and the
other producer who I made the movie with
are looking at it as is you know getting
it out there so that we go make
something else we've had this movie
that's you know had some success and
gotten out there and been seen and
building off of that and then of course
there's you know the fantasy that you
let yourself have every once in a while
that's going to become some big cult hit
and find a you know a lot of fans in
life of its own but you know trying to
temper temper that for you know a little
bit smaller good you know goal
you